donc océanopolis et un centre de culture
scientifique
c'est un organisme en fait qui ya 3 3
différents pavillons à océanopolis on
alpes avions tempéré c'est le premier
qui a été créée océanopolis donc en 1990
ensuite dix ans plus tard le pavillon
polaire et le pavillon tropicale se sont
ajoutés aux circuits de visite
donc le but d'océanopolis et de faire
découvrir au public un maximum de
personnes l'ensemble des océans de notre
planète et ensuite tout ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur tout ce qui s'y rattache
c'est à dire la faune la flore les
techniques de pêche
voilà tout ce qui est environnement
marin derrière on dans le pavillon
tempérer je commençais par celui-là
parce que c'est le premier qui a été
créé ouvert au public a récemment police
ne le pavillon tempéré retrace tout ce
qui est faune flore de la mer de breteil
donc dedans vous retrouvez les poissons
vous retrouve aussi des requins vous
retrouve aussi des phoques les phoques
veaux marins les phoques gris
ensuite on a le pavillon polaire alors
le pavillon polaire il se déroule en
deux parties d'abord on va commencer au
niveau du pôle sud l'hémisphère sud avec
le continent antarctique
alors ça commence par
le visionnage d'un film qui a été tourné
dans les îles subantarctiques crozet
kerguelen et amsterdam qui sont des îles
françaises
ensuite ça continue non par la visite de
la manche au tiers avec trois espèces de
manchots à l'intérieur papou gorfous
sauteurs et manchot royal voilà prêt ya
différents mammifères marins également
qu'on peut voir avec notamment
l'éléphant de mer des animaux
naturalisés sur lequel voilà on explique
beaucoup de choses
ensuite c'est le passage l'hémisphère
nord avec toute une exposition sur les
inuits la culture inuite comment ils
vivent aujourd'hui les phoques leurs
relations avec les phoques également les
bourses scolaires et on termine la
visite du pavillon polaire par les fonds
les fonds des pôles donc
il ya voilà il ya différents animaux
différentes présentations avec des
étoiles
enfin je veux dire des anémones de mer
pour montrer justement que malgré format
une idée du fonds des pôles qui est
assez vide sans vie sans couleur est
justement là on voit qu'avec les
anémones de mer présenté série très
riche de couleurs on a du rouge du vert
voilà on en prend plein les yeux et
juste avant de sortir en fait on peut
revoir les fois que les fois que
précédent vu du dessus c'est à dire on
peut les voir sur la banquise comme ça
faire leur petit exercice de nourrissage
également manipuler par par les
animaliers des services ces mammifères
marins et oiseaux et mon dernier
pavillon d'océanopolis et le pavillon
tropicale là c'est vraiment un tour du
monde qui s'effectue tout au courant
tout au long de la visite on commence
par le père par l'océan pacifique avec
toute une démonstration des explications
sur les requins leur au mode de vie où
ils vivent comme ils sont comment est-ce
qu'ils chassent comment est ce qu'ils se
reproduisent ouais c'est vraiment essayé
de voir le maximum de choses de façon
ludique et abordable pour tout public
ensuite il ya aussi une présentation sur
la barrière de corail
ensuite on continue la visite par le
poisson de recife où vous lie à pas loin
de 150 espèces différentes dans ce
bassin qui ont tous des couleurs des
formes différentes continue par la mer
des caraïbes avec des tortues notamment
les tortues caouannes et pour terminer
la visite donc dû pallier mon c'est la
forêt équatoriale
donc avec de véritables plantes on a
essayé vraiment de recréer plus proche
possible de la réalité
les conditions tant atmosphérique que
température
niveau de la pression de l'eau dit et
c'est tout est vraiment le plus proche
de la réalité et en également des
animaux endémiques en fait qu'ils vivent
dans mon portefeuille des petits verres
des têtards les petites choses comme ça
qui sont visibles du coupon public quand
on passe sur le säntis au milieu
voilà